j'ai foi en la venue du messie
c'est une des premières chansons
enseigné dans ce jardin d'enfants de
chasse le mouvement orthodoxe des juifs
orientaux de 7h30 le matin à 17h29 mille
enfants israéliens sont gratuitement
prise en charge par cette organisation
qui dans les quartiers défavorisés et
les villes de développement remplacent
les services sociaux de l'état
notoirement insuffisant ces crèches
jardins d'enfants écoles primaires
constituent la grande force de chasse
car 50% des élèves viennent de familles
non religieuse
notre but principal est de former
l'enfant au plan social éducative et
aussi des valeurs bien entendu nos
établissements sont souvent les seuls de
leur genre dans certains quartiers
certaines villes et les familles
reviennent ainsi à la fois résultats
avec dix députés chassé depuis les
dernières élections le troisième parti
politique du pays
un succès formidable après seulement
douze années d'existence à sa tête se
trouve le rabbin ovadia yossef
grâce à des alliances avec tous les
gouvernements de gauche comme de droite
il a pu assurer le financement par
l'état des activités de son amour
tout en affichant des opinions
pragmatique sur le conflit avec les
palestiniens
il est l écoute de son électorat qui a
voté pour benyamin netanyahu à plus de
95 % au-dessus il y a le guide suprême
l'inventeur de cette nouvelle orthodoxie
centenaire patron de cette école
talmudique près de tel-aviv le rabbin
eliezer chars n'apparaît que très
rarement devant les caméras
outre chasse ils contrôlent un autre
parti de juifs occidentaux et c'est son
député le rabbin rawitz qui préside la
très influente commission parlementaire
des finances
le nerf de la guerre marco sturm chat
mais nous voulons que l'état soit juif
dans tous ces symboles pour nous
l'observance du repos du shabbat est
indispensable surtout ce qui est public
par exemple il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
de transport en commun et que les
magasins soient ouverts le samedi
même dans les quartiers laïque c'est
ainsi qu'à jérusalem les orthodoxes ont
renforcé les manifestations pour que
cette rue qui passe par leur secteur
soit fermé le cem et pour les très
laïque guignols israélien le rabbin
ovadia yossef est un grand pas qu'ils
eater il a en effet déclaré que les
mécréants qui enfreignent le shabbat
merrick la mort
théocratie où pays moderne la bataille
sur la nature même de l'état d'israël
est entrée dans une nouvelle phase on
vit aujourd'hui dans une crise
d'identité ou israël ne sait pas où il
va et c'est là la question que se posent
les israéliens est ce qu'on est
est ce qu'on peut faire la paix avec les
arabes à ce qu'ont pu vivre avec les des
non-juifs d'une façon normale
ou est ce qu'on est on doit rester dans
notre forteresse public judaïque
spirituel de la réponse à cette question
dépend aussi l'avenir du processus de
paix en israël dominé par le
nationalisme et l'orthodoxie religieuse
ne renoncera pas facilement à la terre
promise biblique